اذا مشاهدينا هذه الصور المباشره من من
نيويورك من الولايات المتحده
للتلوث الذي نتج عن
الحرائق المشتعله في كندا والتي طبعا هي
حرائق غير مسبوقه وصنفت بانها الاكبر منذ
اعوام
وطبعا هناك العديد منها خارج عن السيطره
ساذكر مشاهدينا بان بلغ بانه قد بلغ مؤشر
جوده الهواء في نيويورك 167 درجه وهو رقم
كبير جدا قياسا
للمؤشرات العاديه هو ما يشير طبعا الى
ارتفاع التلوث الى مستويات خطيره تؤثر على
صحه الانسان اذا قررت اداره الطيران
الفيدرالي الامريكي توقيف رحلات جويه الى
مدينه نيويورك بسبب ضعف الرؤيه الناتج عن
حرائق الغابات وقالت اداره طيران ان
الرحلات الجويه المتجهه الى مطار نيويورك
اما توقفت مؤقتا او تاخرت عن موعد وصولها
فيما غطى دخان الحرائق سمك سماء نيويورك
ومبدا الامم المتحده وهذه مشاهدينا صور
مباشره لمطار نيويورك حيث ايضا غطى الدخان
كل المدرجات وكل سماء المطار مما يؤثر
ومما يؤثر على حركه الملاحه الجويه
اذا مشاهدينا اعيد بان هذه الصور المباشره
لمطار نيويورك والتي تظهر ايضا بان السماء
حمراء وهناك صعوبه طبعا للخروج وصعوبه
لتسيير الملاحه الجويه مما دفع بالسلطات
هناك الى ايقاف الحركه الجويه بعد بعدما
يعني
تاثرت مدينه نيويورك بشكل كبير بالحرائق
التي اندلعت في كندا ووصلت مستويات التلوث
بهذه المدينه الى مستويات غير مسبوقه تؤثر
على صحه الانسان طبعا وبحسب الاداره هناك
فان الجسيمات الدقيقه مشاهدينا الموجوده
في الهواء هي من بين الاكثر اكثر الجسيمات
ضررا على صحه الانسان وعلى
الانسان الذي يعاني من امراض الجهاز
التنفسي ومن امراض قلب وبالتالي هنا نصحت
السلطات المعنيه المواطنين بعدم الخروج
وبعدم التعرض للهواء الا في حال الضروره
طبعا وفقا طبعا لوسائل اعلام امريكيه فان
مدينه نيويورك عاده تستوعب في المتوسط
مشاهدينا بين 35 ميكرو جراما من الجسيمات
الدقيقه لكل متر مكعب من الهواء يوميا وقد
ارتفع هذا العدد مع او هذا الرقم مع
اندلاع الحرائق في كندا الى 140 وصولا الى
160 ومن المتوقع بحسب التقارير هناك ان
يصل الى
335 الليله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات